nous on va rester fermés au moins
jusqu'à fin janvier d'après les échos
qu'on a on est encore pour mes trois
mois de fermeture
ça va être compliqué maintenant mais
alors fin janvier la question est ce que
vous pouvez tenir économiquement jusqu'à
fin janvier
ah si le cil et ajouts jeu on va pouvoir
tenir ça va être très très compliqué ça
manque de solidarité on a parlé de
solidarité tout à l'heure moi je voulais
poser la question en madame la ministre
parce que monsieur macron avait évoqué
les assurances les assurances on les
entend pas beaucoup faut savoir que
l'entreprise comme la mienne c'est à peu
près vingt mille euros de charges fixes
mensuels
donc on a déjà eu on aura eu cinq fois
cette année si on commence avec un mois
de fermeture
et puis il faut savoir si on aura pas
d'autres fermetures
c'est nous on a le métier de
convivialité on me demande de me
réinventer moi je sais pas vraiment me
réinventer je serai inventé ça veut tout
dire et rien dire 'nous' réinventer dans
la livraison c'est pratiquement
impossible
en plus ça nous oblige à temps parce que
c'est impossible parce que ça m'a obligé
à travailler des centrales qui abusent
de leurs employés qui laisse on paye
c'est carrément le contraire que de ce
que nous voulons faire carrément plus la
pollution que ça implique par les
assiettes par les sacs par tout le
plastique qu'on met pour la livraison
faut pas l'oublier non plus mais on
entend beaucoup parler c'est une réalité
des aides massives qui sont accordées au
restaurant il ya d'autres commerces est
ce que vraiment elles sont arrivées
est-ce que vous avez déjà touché ces
aides parce que j'ai entendu certains de
vos confrères dire qu'il les attend
toujours pour le premier confinement n'a
rien touché d'accord on a eu le chômage
partiel sur ça nous n'avons rien touché
ça devrait se débloquer pour les mois
qui viennent c'est à dire que
normalement novembre décembre
on nous garantit 10 microns d'accord ce
qui ne couvre pas les frais mais vous
vous attendez quoi de plus qu'est ce que
vous souhaiteriez obtenir comme aide
supplémentaire si ça perdure il y à
beaucoup d'entreprises dans notre milieu
qui vont disparaître les petits qui
n'ont pas eu le temps qu'ils sont créés
depuis deux ans un an
eux n'ont pas le temps de
ils n'ont pas eu le temps de se
constituer de capital donc vont
disparaître moi je connais plein sur
amiens
las dos d'âne plein d'établissement le
bas au bar qu'ils viennent de racheter
eux sont pratiquement condamnés si on
les aide pas pratiquement condamné ces
établissements viables mais qui n'ont
pas eu le temps de se constituer un
capital nous ça va être très compliqué
cinq mois de fermeture dans une année
c'est pas possible on comprend pour tout
commerce ce serait catastrophique et
pour le vôtre et ont notamment cela
c'est en commençant l'année d'après avec
un mois de fermeture si ce n'est qu'un
mois
2 on va voir mais oui ça risque d'être
sévère voilà